an abandoned bus that was made famous by
the John Krakauer book and subsequent
movie into the wild has been airlifted
near a national park in Alaska over the
years many tourists tried to reach the
bus where Christopher McCandless spent
114 days before dying of starvation in
1992 now many of those tourists needed
to be rescued and some even died
yesterday the Alaska National Guard
removed the bus using a heavy lift
helicopter the bus is being stored at a
secure site but discussions are underway
for it to possibly go on display to the
public Tony there were 15 bus related
search-and-rescue operations between
2009 and 2017 and last year a young
woman died trying to reach it yeah I
mean first of all you can see how
beautiful Alaska is those pictures are
stunning it is a tragedy that people
went to find the bus and some of them
lost their lives
I think the McCandless family got some
mementos out of this that were in the
bus some memories the safety of the area
I think goes up a little bit and the
spirit I think it's still contained in
the book in the movie for people who
want to make a kind of pilgrimage so I
think this is good all the way around
glad